every day you're walking down the street
you have a chance to save somebody's
life every day if you start observing
you're going to see people in stress you
can see people in trouble and if you
just give them a kind word give them a
smile when they go home that night they
might have a little different outlook on
life you know and that saves a life with
a simple smile I was walking around
Costco just the other day and we were
creating people left and right and just
being funny and joking with everybody
and you would believe the responses we
got and we just started talking people
need to slow down people need to start
having conversations